[Música]
estos egipcios protestan frente a unos
soldados en el norte del Sinaí una
escena poco común en Egipto donde las
manifestaciones contra el gobierno del
fatal son reprimidas severamente los
manifestantes denuncian desde comienzos
de marzo las operaciones de demolición
de su barrio una zona de 2 kilómetros
cuadrados contigo al puerto de la ciudad
de elarish en el Sinaí en 2019 un
decreto presidencial atribuyó la
propiedad de la zona al Ministerio de
defensa y estableció el objetivo de
ampliar el Antiguo Puerto pesquero de
larish para desarrollar sus actividades
comerciales un residente nos cuenta cómo
han sido las protestas por seguridad su
testimonio es anónimo
Al fin
que
en 2022 el consejo municipal vinculado
al Distrito vino para hacer una
evaluación y verificar nuestras actas de
propiedad al igual que el área de las
casas concluyeron que costaría menos
demoler nuestro barrio que ampliar el
puerto en otra zona
[Música]
se erigió un muro alrededor de todo el
barrio para aislarlo el resto de la
ciudad es una manera de no darnos
alternativa de demostrarnos que ya
perdimos escaso
cuando se demolió la primera casa del
barrio las fuerzas del orden
intervinieron
amenazaron con llevar a prisión a los
habitantes que se opusieron a la
operación
quieren evitar cualquier concentración
porque estas manifestaciones son un
problema para ellos
ha habido amenazas de equipo nos
llevaremos al que persista o no obedezca
las órdenes etcétera
desde 2012 los habitantes de este barrio
han trabajado mano a mano con las
fuerzas armadas en la lucha contra el
terrorismo nuestra recompensa no Debería
ser la expulsión de nuestras casas claro
algunos habitantes han entregado sus
propiedades a las autoridades pero el
gobierno juega con su ignorancia o con
su pobreza
todos los días nos preguntamos si ya
llegaron los equipos de demolición que
casa está siendo destruida si alguien ha
cedido su terreno o no y los medios
locales se niegan a transmitir nuestras
voces imponer un silencio mediático
absoluto sobre todo este asunto e
impedir que se oigan nuestras voces me
parece criminal
lee
[Música]
este hombre estaba a punto de ser
ejecutado por homicidio pero en el
último instante se enteró de que el
padre de su víctima Había decidido
indultarlo ocurrió el 20 de febrero en
Marie en el centro de yemen y este gesto
de perdón despertó el entusiasmo de
muchos yemenitas ya que el país está
desgarrado por un conflicto que opone a
las fuerzas leales al gobierno contra
los Rebeldes desde hace casi 9 años todo
empezó en 2016 rabia aldemas y un joven
proveniente de la tribu Beni javer mató
a saddán al joatí un amigo durante una
disputa rabia fue arrestado y condenado
a muerte por un tribunal pero durante
los días previos a la ejecución de la
sentencia la madre del asesino acampó
delante de la tumba de la víctima para
implorar el perdón de su padre el jefe
de la tribu murat y el 20 de febrero
pasado llegó la buena noticia
nuestro observadora nado a dausari es
una investigadora yemenita vive entre
Estados Unidos y su país de origen su
trabajo académico se centra en el
sistema tribal de yemen las comunidades
tribales las mujeres ocupan un lugar muy
importante son escuchadas en este caso
precisamente el jefe de la tribu aceptó
la petición de la mujer y eso lo
engrandece ante los demás es un gesto
que inspira respeto
esta situación se ha repetido muchas
veces en los últimos años
la familia de la víctima que Perdona la
del asesino y es muy importante para
preservar la paz social
Aunque el autor del homicidio fue
juzgado por un tribunal el sistema
judicial yemenita le confiere al padre
de la víctima el derecho de Gracia según
nuestra observadora desde 2014 las
tribus en yemen hacen todo lo posible
para evitar que la guerra no agrave sus
conflictos internos
desde el comienzo de la guerra las
tribus han congelado sus conflictos
incluso han aprovechado esta oportunidad
para solucionarlos
desde el 2015 este año hace un mes una
mediación en la tribu
permitió solucionar un conflicto que
duraba Desde hacía 80 años
[Aplausos]
las tribus no se conforman con
solucionar sus propios conflictos las
tribus han hecho mucho por mitigar los
efectos de la guerra primero en las
propias tribus pero sobre todo en los
ciudadanos
las tribus intervienen para proteger
edificios públicos para pagar conflictos
recientemente una mediación tribal
permitió reabrir una carretera entre
es una carretera importante para los
ciudadanos para la mercancía estaba
cerrada desde hace un año por la guerra
[Música]
Gracias a todos nuestros observadores
por informarnos sobre lo que ocurre en
sus comunidades si desean ponerse en
contacto con el equipo de observadores
nuestros contactos redes sociales y
teléfonos aparecen en sus pantallas
envíenos fotos y videos nosotros nos
vemos la próxima semana